wir kommen auf 7800 euro es gibt seit
einiger zeit einen neuen trend auf
youtube den trend wie viel ist dein
outfit werk und jetzt frage an euch was
wir also wieso bisherige erfahrung mit
youtube brands hatte baden in für 100
euro arsch anfassen cola auf
also in der vergangenheit hat mir
eigentlich keine probleme ich werde in
diesem video mir diese wunderschönen und
sie in ihrer botschaft perfekten videos
anschauen werde dabei selbst versucht zu
erraten wie teuer die outfits sind
vorsicht sagen und auch sowie videos
reagieren und generell sagen dazu sagen
dann bleibt noch zu sagen heute alle
kanäle von den videos anschauen und in
der beschreibung verlinkt wird es
zeitlich nicht ich muss 20 kinder
versorgen wir also 15 18 17 hier sind
jetzt die bei uns geht bzw 1 7 nicht
dafür haben wir im hintergrund einer
frau ab
das geht hier leute ich würde sagen der
typ ganz links ich bin es keinen moment
machen bevor es losgeht muss ich das mal
laut flexen geht das leider ja ich würde
mal sagen ich bin kein kasse versteckst
weiter ohne mich zwar dass plätze zu
lehnen der typ links wie das normale
kappe vielleicht bomberjacke normaler
pulli 500 1500 in der mitte ich mir
sagen was habt ihr bis mäßig an der gci
kappe aus ist schon irgendwie seine
sonnenbrille der politik relativ so
designer mäßig aus zweieinhalbtausend
euro und der typ auf der rechten seite
sieht auch beim für normal eingezogen
aus der jacke schuld
okay okay das ist ja gar nicht schlecht
gerade von mir deine schuhe von nike die
kosten 90 seine hose
das ist eine tolle rolle schien zu 550
der pullover von gucci der kuss 1300
deine kempowski seine kamera sagen die
kerbs gucci und das stirnband ist auch
gucci die kerb kostet 210 und
stimmungsvollen keinen bock mehr zu
leben herzliche frage was geht mit der
menschheit ab dass man ein stirnband
über einer kappe trägt so bin ich in der
falschen dimension so macht man das aber
das hat dieses stirn waren 200 euro
kostet das extrem die preise direkt
parat hat sowas gibt bei dem ab hatte er
soll auf seinem handy so eine excel
liste wo er immer nachschauen kann und
dann auf den cent genau eintrittskarten
stück kostet ach ja meine meine
augenbrauen auf der rechten seite ja die
sind von ms 1300 euro also das kann
jetzt mal gar nicht verstehen
doch jetzt von mir ich mag okay ich
persönlich bin sehr begeistert
interessiere mich für uhren und ich
würde niemals in meinem leben niemals
wenn ich so viel geld habe dass ich so
viel geld für ein auto ausgeben kann
mehr für einen pulli zahlen als für eine
uhr ein pulli die man zehnmal in die
wäsche haut danach der scheiße aus börse
ist eine uhr die man keine ahnung gefühl
sein ganzes leben an tagen
wenn die was taugt aber sobald ein
begriff und was ist ein kauf delikt 2600
[Musik]
das 7800 euro
alles klar im ernst heute gefeiert
weiter machen dass wir eine sache sagen
das gibt es mal so lebens tipps von mir
okay weil gesagt ich bin 22 jahre hat
deutlich gemacht wenn ihr denkt leute
lasst euch so was glücklich macht das
hier 1000 euro für poly ausgeht oder
keine ahnung 900 euro für schal oder was
weiß ich was ihr wisst was ich meine
glaub mir sowas macht nicht glücklich
man bildet sich ein dass würde eigene
leben kraft verändern und wie geil
während man das tragen würde und das
tragen würde wenn man es dann trägt ist
es nach zwei tagen genauso wie alles
andere als gewöhnlich viel zu kassieren
das ist es nicht wert aber jetzt wieder
weiter leute verarschen unter nächster
kandidat unsere nächste probanten diesem
experiment ich würde sagen normales auto
für die klein bisschen mehr ich sag's
700 euro bei den skischuhen 550-2
valentino 150
preis auf unter gesetzt 360 die eu habe
ich nur für 318 km/h und ein fossil für
80 jahre
die kette von deutschland werben für
habe ich geschenkt bekommen also 120
wurde
kurz mal macht er das auch ich schenke
dir leuten was an sagt dann gleich viel
kostet max alles gute zum geburtstag
übrigens hat ein neues handy kostet 1000
euro
unser sagte für alles klar
ich habe verkackt ein schwede 2000 euro
naja ich verlasse mich ganz auf mich
nicht gibt mir irgendwo die 2700
funktion ab kostet dann die hose ist
toll island 280 gekostet können wir uns
darüber reden wie beschissenes aussieht
dass sich doch um einen dinge auf einer
rose drauf ist aber auch michael keiner
nation t shirt wird also 30 unterhose
kostet also 360 weiß es nicht aushalten
dreifach gekauft einfach alles was mit
der menschen falls er sagt unter fotos
in 360 gekauft und dann kann er nicht
sagen wie viele einst in der hose kurzen
zeit geschah kurz 80 und 650 jacke 600
die uhr kostet auch 600 hoch sagt hast
du viel kostet 200 euro
ja ich befreiter sklave einmal 3000 euro
und selbst problem ist einfach ok nevada
sind nicht günstiger als doch die große
politik
ich habe auf jeden fall nach diesem
video metacafe schlossen heute ich zeige
euch jetzt noch mein outfit tipp für den
frühling 2008 zehnter damit könnt ihr
aber seid jeden tag durch die stadt
gehen und sie selber versichern und zwar
ist der gehalte leute im jahr alpha ein
weißes 10x l t shirt das muss auch in
dem fall nicht mehr von oft sein ich
weiß nicht was ich glauben aber einfach
so sieht man auch überhaupt nicht die
muskeln da stehen auch alle drauf und
dann heute geht nicht rum und zeigt
leuten eure marken etiketten oder so
zeigt mir einfach in eurem t shirt zeigt
ein einfaches 10x alltag müssen nicht
unbescheiden fest für das jahr 2010 ich
hier in folge was das field verlinkt da
zeige ich auch regelmäßig welche outfits
fürs kleine budget unter 100000 euro man
so kaufen kann